okay now here's a question what's the
biggest living organism on the planet a
whale a redwood tree arguably it's our
malaria a huge honey fungus living in a
forest in Oregon USA it covers over nine
square kilometers and is thought to be
at least 2 400 years old oh and it glows
in the dark mind blown
what if we also told you that other
types of fungi can absorb oil spills
control insects brains and that fungi in
general are essential to all terrestrial
life on Earth
and there's still so much we don't know
more than 90 of the fungi in the world
are currently unknown to science
who could say there's mushroom for
learning now that we've got that
terrible pun out of the way we can take
a closer look at some fascinating facts
that will make you a real fun guy at
parties
sorry if you think of mushrooms as
vegetables on your pizza You Are Not
Alone thanks to the Victorian botanists
who classified fungi with plants in fact
fungi are neither plant nor animal they
are in a kingdom of their own but a
genetically much closer to animals the
genetic code of a mushroom has more in
common with hours than a potatoes maybe
don't mention that to your vegan friends
fungi also have the ability to control
other organisms while some species of
fungi break down Dead Leaves and wood
like The Helpful housemate who always
remembers to take the bins out other
fungi are mycorrhizal they plug into the
root tissue of plants and pass precious
nutrients between them this process
forms a dense fungal Network called a
mycelium soil often contains masses of
these mycelial threads connecting
different plants like fiber optic cables
in woods the network is known as the a
wood Wide Web because plants use it to
communicate with one another
in a fertile pasture the fungi feeding
on Plants below ground can be many times
heavier than the cows eating the grass
above it
some fungi get other species to do the
work for them the leukogaricus uses
chemical signals to employ leaf cutter
ants the ants work together to form a
supply chain that can deliver up to 60
000 Leaf fragments an hour to the fungus
in return it produces minuscule
ant-sized mushrooms to feed them other
fungi employ more gruesome methods
cordyceps infiltrate their insect host
for example ants or beetles and control
their brains forcing them to climb up
high and then bursting out of their
bodies to scatter their spores to the
wind
talk about Evil Genius not to content
with insect mind control some types of
fungi can trouble humans causing
irritations like athlete's foot as well
as the more deadly histoplasmosis
ergot a fungus that grows on wheat and
rye can literally send you mad eating
bread made from affected flour is likely
to have contributed to mass
hallucinations in medieval Europe and
you don't have to be a seasoned forager
to know that some species of fungi are
highly toxic
if I were you I'd avoid anything with an
intimidating biker gang name like Autumn
skull cap or destroying angels while
fungi can in some cases be extremely
dangerous they are also an invaluable
resource for a start fungi produce
life-saving medicines such as penicillin
yeast is a fungus without which we'd
have no bread wine beer or cheese even
corn is made from a fungus basically
without fungi there would be no middle
class dinner parties
mycelium can be used to make packaging
and clothing funky have been used to
clean up oil spills and an etoconic acid
derived from a fungus is even used to
make Lego fungi are also Eco Warriors
they are absolutely essential to a
healthy soil and play a key role in
trapping CO2 fixed by plants into the
soil preventing its return to the
atmosphere over a thousand billion tons
of carbon are locked in the world's
soils that's more than twice the amount
of carbon held by all the trees on Earth
if the activity of soil fungi were to
increase they could potentially solve
global warming on their own but despite
their many uses and dangers of course
funky aren't actually good or evil they
are an incredibly adaptable and distinct
life form playing a key role in
terrestrial life on the planet and for
that and not just because they taste
great on pizzas they should be
celebrated
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video